hi i'm jane levy and i play zoe
hi i'm john claren stewart and i play
simon hi
i'm alex newell and i play mo and i'm
mary steenbridgen and i play maggie
hi i'm skyler aston i play max on zoe's
extraordinary playlist we are the cast
of zoe's extraordinary playlist and we
are here with buzzfeed today to take a
quiz
to find out which character from the
show we actually
are
how would your bffs describe you smart
funny creative charming loyal or
passionate
i'm told that they find me creative
my friends find me very creative as well
i think skyler's is hard because i
always think that skyler's like really
smart
to the point where you're like are you
okay you're too smart but you're also
really funny and charming how do you
pick between charming and funny i think
charming
that's so sweet i would choose
passionate for you john well dog dog
dagnabbit now jane
i for some reason just like based on how
i'm feeling like
right now for some reason it's funny i
know jane you're so surprised
i'll take it okay bunny what song would
you sing in karaoke
bad guy by billy eilish single ladies by
beyonce
wannabe by spice girls i want to dance
with somebody by whitney houston come on
eileen by
dexi's midnight runners and shake it off
by taylor swift
[Music]
i'm going whitney houston i'll get billy
eilish you know i love my whitney so i'm
just gonna have to go if i want to dance
with somebody
you should love your whitney because you
crush
the songs that whitney sang when you
sing them i
really love billy eilish and i love bad
guy
pick a movie musical to watch singing in
the rain dream girls the greatest
showmen
the sound of music a star is born in
greece
a star is born because my friend bradley
cooper did the last version of it my
other friend barbara did the previous
version of it
so i'm gonna go with starsborne it's the
casual my friend is barbra streisand for
me
all right i'm gonna drop that mine will
always be dream girls because effie
white is one of my dream roles to play
on broadway
i'm just trying to manifest it i'm going
with singing in the rain
i'm going with uh grease although dream
girls came really close because i had a
really great experience seeing that i'm
going to the side of music it reminds me
of my mama she used to sing that stuff
which zoe's extraordinary playlist
character would you
trust with a secret tobin
deb leaf emily david my darling son
or dale emily seems like a steel trap
emily is still trapped and she's my
daughter-in-law
so i'm gonna go with emily i feel like
you could tell her a
full secret and she wouldn't she'd
forget that she had it
i'm gonna pick um deb i'd go deb because
she has like nothing to lose like
she's not going to prove amazing
actually i think i'm going deb
as well which of zoe's heart songs is
your favorite so far
american pie i'm going to be 500 miles
the great pretender
happier fight song true colors i'm gonna
go with american pie
i'm gonna go happier john i'm gonna go
i'm gonna be
my absolute favorite song and season one
is not on here which is you singing this
little light of mine
i came in early to get through hair
makeup
to go stand in the back of the room and
watch you but
on this list i'm gonna pick american pie
because that was such a momentous
experience
doing that seven minute song that's a
single
shot that involved every single one of
us knowing exactly where to be at every
moment
every time i see true colors happen
i start bombing so i'm obsessed i'm
obsessed i'm obsessed
finally if you were to gas star on any
of these tv shows
which one would it be shit's creek
grey's anatomy
stranger things the good place
good girls or fleabag i'm gonna say
shit's creek
well i'm gonna say the good place
because i'm
married to the angel slash demon michael
and i don't wanna provoke him fleabag
back mine was between strange stranger
things and fleabag but i'm going to take
stranger things
i got maggie you got maggie oh jesus
i got joan damn i got simon
whoa i caught zoe that's fitting
you guys damn your personality matches
maggie you're creative honest and
genuine
you're the mom of the group you're
constantly looking out for it
you're right i don't look out for anyone
your personality
matches joan your head strong passionate
and intelligent sometimes you have to be
reminded to take a break from work and
just have some fun with friends
that i love i love both of your like
last sentiments
i got simon you're thoughtful
compassionate and hard-working
you're a hopeless romantic who still
believes that the one is out there
somewhere
you are creative ambitious and loyal
like mo you're someone who marches in
feet of your own drum and you don't care
what others think
your personality matches zoe you're
smart
courageous and intuitive your family is
very important to you and you often put
their needs
above your own who wrote this they're so
kind
you